as Americans hope to get back to normal
the experts say we need more widespread
diagnostic testing for this coronavirus
first on CBS this morning our senior
medical correspondent that's dr. Tara
Narula
spoke to a top medical advocate who
thinks the government could be doing
more we are still not where we need to
be in terms of testing or coping 19
that's the warning from dr. David
Skorton president of the Association of
American Medical Colleges it's echoed in
a letter he sent to the White House
coronavirus Task Force this week calling
for more federal involvement in the
testing process we were not ready for
such a big big deal as this pandemic has
become according to the Cova tracking
project more than 3.2 million tests have
been run in the United States that's
enough for less than 1% of the country
and it falls short of what experts say
is needed to reopen America the American
Enterprise Institute estimates 750,000
tests per week are needed other groups
put that number in the millions as
reported infections continue to rise
many testing sites across the country
are being met with long lines one site
in Miami closed after 90 minutes Monday
because it already reached capacity I
was very frustrated in fact after I got
to phone with them I cried and Americans
say they're still having trouble with
testing access searcy Farrell says she
was denied a coronavirus test five times
as her symptoms got worse even after her
doctor recommended one Farrell said she
was concerned about her mother who is
immunocompromised if my mom wakes up and
she can't breathe and I've got a rush
her to the emergency room I need to be
able to tell them I'm Kobi positive what
has been the biggest rate limiting
factor in terms of quickly scaling up
testing it actually hasn't been one
thing but because there are probably
between 20 and 30 very specific things
that are needed to report each
individual test there is a slightly
different bottleneck in any of those
different things that we need LabCorp
one of America's largest private labs
says it can perform 55 to 65 thousand
tests per day chief medical officer dr.
Brian caveny tells CBS this morning they
want to continue increasing that testing
capacity if possible we have to have
every one of those supplies in the right
amount so that we can go through our lab
specimens and process them as
efficiently as possible
what types of problems do we face if we
do not ramp up testing quick enough in
order to understand the basic substrate
that we're dealing with the basic number
of people who have it whether or not
they have symptoms we have to be ready
for extensive testing but we can't just
pretend we're going to go back to
business as usual
Tara we just can't get this testing
right and it's so critical to the
process so how do we get to the point
where we are testing the numbers of
people that the experts say that we
should be testing in a timely manner
well Gil everybody says it's one word
leadership leadership from the federal
government and at a state level and also
combined action with the private sector
we need this test to be ubiquitous to be
efficient and to have a rapid turnaround
time without that experts say we're
really flying blind and it's not just a
question of reopening the economy but
really keeping the economy open so the
two issues are building stronger lab
platforms the ability to run the tests
the machinery and also fixing those
problems on the supply side so the
issues with the swabs and the reagents
if we can do that both quickly then
hopefully we can successfully reopen the
economy and keep it open yeah but as you
said it starts with leadership thank you
Tara